Yeah, oh, no.
>> Ah, this guy doesn't know the history at all and so
he's going to make an ass out of himself. Oh my god, did we just
>> tax the incels? Am I arguing to tax the incels? OH MY
GOD. OH, NO, HE'S THE LIBERAL TRAPDOOR SPIDER. He's the guy from
the Stone Toss comic. No, no.
Okay, this guy if you gotten a good taste for like this guy and
how he's a little soy, all right, I did want to check out this
this debate again tonight. Rachel Wilson, Brian Shapiro.
These two are debating, okay? And I've heard that this [__]
popped off, that this [__] is crazy. She would not
have been paid to write her book
if not for feminism and the people that work really hard to give
her the opportunity to do this. Now, listen, I don't care how
much money she's getting paid. It wasn't even that long ago where
were in abusive relationships, but they weren't allowed to get
out of those
I don't care about someone's personal life. I don't care how
many baby daddies they have.
No way. He's hitting Rachel on the baby daddies immediately.
That's 2 minutes into the debate. Immediately brings up the baby
daddies.
>> I don't care how many ex-husbands they have. It's not
my business. But in this debate, it is my business because she's
telling other people how they should live their life.
Why is it okay for her to do that, but not others? I defer.
Thank you very much. [snorts] THIS WOMAN HAS BENEFITED FROM being
a or not being held accountable. HOW COULD ANDREW WILSON POSSIBLY
defend this? I defer to Andrew Wilson's wife. Andrew Wilson's
wife got anything to say?
Bro, what? >> Watch for at Andrew Wilson's event, the Uncensored
America event. This is crazy. It's a crazy tactic to take. >> For that
opening statement, we're going to kick it over to Rachel for
her 5-minute opening as well. Rachel, I have the timer set for
you. The floor is all yours. Okay, I'm going to skip through
her opening and get to the next segment. We know most of Rachel's
positions, right? I feel like we know feminism is bad, women
having suffrage is is not great. Um, women joining the workforce
actually degrades the family, lowers birth rates. I I feel like
we don't need the whole >> as well. We will jump into the
rebuttals. These are 5 minutes as well. Brian, I've got the timer
set for you. The floor is all yours.
The word would be hypocrisy.
Rachel just talked about abuse,
I want to be very clear with what I'm about to say.
It is normally not my business. Normally, I would never do this
to a regular person, but this stupid [__] I would
never do this to a normal empathetic human, but this evil [__]
>> to talk about how many children you how many ex-husbands
you have. Dude. But when you have This guy is like this guy is
the powder version of Tree of Logic, okay? He watched like eight
different Tree of Logic streams and came in equipped, ready to
go. >> how many children you have, how many ex-husbands
you have.
But when you have somebody to my left who wants to tell other
women how to live their lives, I'm going to bring this up and
I'm going to bring up some studies.
Now, Rachel has three baby daddies. Why is that important?
Well, Guzzo and Firsberg study says that if you do have multiple
baby daddies,
the family has higher stress, more likely to have more mental
health issues, the things that you claim that you care so much
about. I do as well.
Uh, the Doria study, lower income and families most likely and
children have a lower education rate. The Rutgers study, you
just talked about physical violence.
The Rutgers study, which by the way, these studies have just
come out in the last couple years. You could look it up if you
would like on your phone. By the way, you want to go back to
50 years or 100 years ago, then why do you use a cell phone?
I'm just curious. Why do you use a cell phone? You can laugh,
but if you want to go back to the way things were 50 or 100 years
ago, we were a slavery nation. Are we still a slavery nation
now? Do you want to go back to slavery? Should black people be
allowed to vote? I'd love you to answer those questions, but
anyway
Um, all right, this is a weird argument. Honestly, it's just
that used to need kids, used to have a farm, you needed a lot
of kids. You don't really need kids
Like that honestly, you had kids because you had to take care
of your own family unit. The way people thrived in the world
was they took care of their own family units. With the advent
of cities, with cities getting massive, you just no longer have
the same pressures to have kids so you can get taken care of
in your dotage, right? It's not the same world you live in. All
the population is in cities. That's why the birth rate's falling
is because everybody moves to the cities. Anyway, going back
to that Rutgers study, if you have multiple baby A lot of kids
would die, too? Yeah, a lot of kids would die, but I mean, realistically,
that wasn't such a problem in, you know, 50 years ago or something.
It's that you like way more people lived on farms or lived in,
you know, suburban America. Also, life was subsidized a decent
amount. But the the falling birth rate is always going to be
tied to increased urbanization. That there was just a larger
proclivity for people to live on farms or live outside of the
major rural or sorry, major urban centers. There's lower density
like lower density rural areas now. Like basically it's been
hollowed out. So, that that is as people move to cities, there's
less space, it's more expensive to have a big family. Um, you
get none of the benefits of having a kid that you normally have
on a farm. It is just no incentive structure there, man.
>> there's a much higher rate. In fact, a
higher risk of physical violence and
Um, the Halpern study,
among other studies, you're likely to be below the poverty line
if you have multiple baby daddies. Now, you might tell me right
now and I would believe you if you said, "I got through it. My
kids grew up to be great people." And I think Rachel's argument
is just going to be that that's not the way anyone should live
their life. I went through struggles and if I'd had this outlook,
I wouldn't have gone through these struggles cuz I would have
selected better. That's how Rachel's going to argue this, right?
Like this guy's doing all of these things and it's like Rachel's
basically going to go, "Yeah, I'm an example." That's how all
of the grifty conversations go. "Well, I'm an example of how
you shouldn't do this." Well, sometimes they're grifty. I I assume
it could be sincere sometimes. Like maybe Rachel might feel totally
sincere that basically finding herself a husband who is willing
to take care of her and and as long as he had authority like
everything's taken care of. Maybe that she truly feels that that
was the thing that made her life way better. He might totally
believe this, but it is he's not arguing against what she's going
to argue. He's arguing that like without feminism, you wouldn't
have been able to get out of those relationships. And she's like,
"Yeah, I should never been in them in the first place. That's
the point of feminism or that's the point of me deriving feminism."
>> And I would say I'm happy for you. I think that's great.
But why is it okay for you, but not okay for them? Why is it
okay for you to say, "Well, you know what? I made some Maybe
you won't say it was mistakes. I don't know. I'll ask you. But
why would it be okay for you hypothetically to say,
"I made some mistakes, but, you know, everything turned out okay.
My kids turned out okay." Why can't other women use those same
excuses if they have kids after 30 or if they want their own
If you want to be a stay-at-home mom with kids, I think that's
great. Go ahead and do that. But if you want to be out there
in the workforce and be a doctor or a lawyer, you should be allowed
to do that, too, and Bible thumpers shouldn't be telling you
what you should or shouldn't do. That's exactly what you do,
Rachel. So, I'd like you to explain to this audience right now
why it's okay for you to have three baby daddies, why it's okay
for you to take those risks in those studies that I just mentioned
for your kids,
but why is it not okay for everybody
Yeah, this is he has not really thought about this at all. You
could You could just attack them for this. You could say they're
they're hypocrites. You could do
but you better think about what the response will be. The way
he set this up is she's not going to argue it's like okay or
that's a good lifestyle. She's going to say that was a mistake
and he will she will say it's a mistake. Not that her kids are
mistakes, but her living her life that way, that she wasn't certain
in her partnerships and such, that was a mistake.
We will switch over to Rachel for her 5-minute rebuttal. Got
the timer set for you, Rachel. The floor is all yours. So, what
you just heard was amateur hour of somebody who does not know
how to make an argument, somebody who doesn't know what a debate
is or how to ad hominem attack.
You can't interrupt. You can't. Well, you can't interrupt during
the rebuttal. >> No, go ahead. Again, amateur hour. Uh,
this is the person who did the ad hominem attacks. He didn't
present an argument. He just said, "What about you?" He used
a two quote Like realistically, if Rachel could sit there and
listen to you critique her baby daddies and [__]
without without opening her mouth, then surely you could do the
same when she says that was amateur hour and you suck. Right?
You're attacking her family, her like core
And And he's like trying to cut in now that she says this is
amateur hour. >> quote wait fallacy. What about you, Uh,
this debate has nothing to do with my life or your life or my
personal life or your personal life.
Control yourself, Brian. >> Yeah. Sean, please mute Brian.
Staggering lack of self-control. So, uh, again, another He looks
so bad doing it, >> fallacy, a straw man fallacy. My argument
was not that I can tell women what to do. Uh, my whole entire
opening was just explaining what has happened to society in general,
going over data. There was no condemnation of working mothers.
There was no condemnation of women who need to leave abusive
relationships like I did. There was no, "We need to go back to
slavery," which was 50 years ago, I guess. Again, uh, not sure
how this person is employed in
But, uh, the all that aside, he did not address any of the arguments
I made, which were
Actually, what he did was support my arguments by saying, "Yeah,
when families are broken up, it's bad for kids. When we see divorce,
rampant divorce, children raised in single in household families,
it's He actually did do this. She's not wrong that he did just
did this. And I'm guessing she's had this debate like a hundred
times. If you come and talk about how her life is because she's
got all these baby daddies or whatever, she's going to go, "Yeah,
that's the whole point I make is I learned that this is a really
bad way to live your Bad for kids. >> Yes, it is. Now,
if everyone was only getting divorced in instances of abuse or
abandonment, we would see divorce rates much closer to numbers
that we had prior to no-fault. You would see
If if you look at surveys, the reasons for divorce, things like
legitimate physical abuse are very far down on the list. They're
usually like fourth or fifth. The number one reason is uh irreconcilable
differences. Well, I just I fell out of love. Mr. Johnson down
the street makes me feel I need to find myself. And the kids
are resilient and they'll get over it. What I'm against is this
frivolous
breaking down of families to chase personal happiness. Uh it's
The kids don't get over it. We have massive studies on what happens
to children after divorce. And as Brian brilliantly laid out,
it's very bad for kids. We see the worst outcomes for children
coming from broken homes. So, the argument is not no one can
get divorced. The argument is divorce should only be permitted
for very good reasons. That was the historic norm for the church.
I'm not saying that women can't work outside the home ever. I'm
saying that mothers already have a full-time job and that pushing
them to work outside the home, creating the two-income trap that's
been laid for us by feminism reduced women's choices. It
The two-income trap.
I would love to hear more about that. Is she just talking about
how
like slowly the standard of living has gone down to or normalized
when people have two incomes in the same home? >> give
us more choices. There was never a time when women were not allowed
to work. It just wasn't the norm because women already had a
full-time job, especially prior to the birth control pill in
1965,
when most women had an average of three to seven kids, depending
on what time frame you're looking at. That's a full-time job.
It didn't make sense to send women out to do men's jobs. It didn't
make any sense to push them outside the home and force them to
work. And now women like me who want to stay home struggle and
and find that they can't and find that they have to work when
all they really want to do is be at home raising their own children.
And they're forced to try to outsource that, which is why most
women only have one or two children anymore. You can't afford
to put five kids in daycare. So, we have very small families,
we have lower birth rates, and we have unhappy
Is it a cost issue that people don't have kids? I think it probably
is a cost issue to some extent.
I'm trying to think if it's mostly a cost issue cuz you do get
diminishing returns for a lot of costs as you have more kids.
like a ton of the work that you put into raising your family,
like making meals and buying clothes, all the like there can
be hand-me-downs. You can do a lot of You can do a lot of economic
saving. There's there's like um diminishing returns on how much
more each kid costs.
I miss you. Well, I'm I'm just talking about like is it really
that much worse now than it was before? And I don't know that
that's the case.
Daycare costs I understand she's saying daycare costs. But like
at some point, it just becomes more profitable for you to stay
at home, right, and take care of your kids.
So, it's about having I guess maybe the argument would be maybe
this is the argument she's making is if you're in a lower class,
if you are in like a working class family, if you want to have
a second kid or sorry, if you want to have like multiple kids,
you probably need a stay-at-home parent and that most lower class
families can't survive on a single salary
and and like have a home or anything like that as they could
as much as they could or as easily as they could in the '50s,
'40s, '50s, '60s. happier women who are now trapped in a different
set of bad circumstances with abusive cohabitating partners instead
of a husband who loves them and takes care of them. We're trapped
in this two-income trap. We have women who are trying to juggle
everything and balance everything and are struggling to do that
and they're reporting higher levels of anxiety and
I'm not here to condemn women. Brian's here to condemn me personally,
apparently, which is the actual ad hominem argument. If he had
an actual argument rather than just pointing at that would be
fine. But if all he's here to do is say, "Well, but you got divorced
because you were in an abusive marriage." That's that's actually
not an argument. It supports my argument that you should be able
to get out of abusive marriages and you were. You were actually
able to get out of abusive marriages prior to no-fault. No-fault
means you don't need a reason and the other party does not have
to agree. And that's where I think that we went wrong.
Thank you very much for that rebuttal from Rachel. We're going
to So, we're going into the 40-minute
crossfire or open dialogue. Okay. I'm going to trust you guys,
but if there are interruptions, I do have to jump in and break
it into 90-second responses. So, handing it off to you. The floor
is
Well, first of all, for somebody that wants to stay home, you're
you're certainly out a lot debating people. So, I really don't
understand that argument. Well, are you aware This guy's like
such a worm. I don't know how else to describe him. Like like
yeah, he is like every bad stereotype of a liberal dude, isn't
he? Like he's just like wormy. He's like such a low testosterone
Shh. What the Well, let me address that since this is a back
and forth. Can I just finish? >> is a back and forth. I
know, but that was like 10 seconds. >> already got it wrong.
So, Can I Can I please Can I Can I please Can I please be allowed
to finish right now, please? Moderator Moderator, please. My
children are
>> You got everything wrong. >> No, I got everything
wrong. >> I know they're grown. Can I just finish? Can
I just finish? So, I've never said that women can't leave the
house when their kids have grown up and left Do you believe women
should be allowed to vote? >> Do you think women are chained
to the kitchen? I'm asking you a question. Do you think women
should be allowed to vote? I think it would be better if women
and many other groups didn't vote. I I would categorize women
as [laughter] one of
Wait. Wait, what? Many other Many other groups? I think it'd
be great if women and many other groups couldn't vote. Wait,
where are the other groups? What? Wait, huh? Is there any other
demo that shouldn't be allowed to vote or is it just one? >> Yeah,
I think there's a lot of different ways that you could limit
suffrage that would make everything a lot more fair and a lot
more efficient. I think that if you're taking more from the system
than you get, so that would be a great way to limit suffrage.
You'd have to be a net zero taxpayer. You can't be taking Oh,
I see. She's going to have a lot of things I Listen.
I mean, man, that last debate really changed my opinion on Andrew
Wilson. I like a fairly solid opinion. I I think I felt Andrew
was like a good person. I'm going to try to hold back a little
bit. But that last debate really changed how I think. Usually,
I'm like, "Well, these guys aren't racist. I know Andrew isn't
racist." As much as people always think Andrew is racist, it's
he's not really. And now Now, for me, I'm like, "Dude, I
I don't know." Cuz when you say net taxpayers, it's obvious that
that's going to fall disproportionately on certain communities,
right? People who are not net net taxpayers at all. more than
you're getting. Get the impression he's not. Andrew is not racist.
Andrew doesn't make arguments about like racial hierarchies or
anything like that. He never has. At most, he could do like a
racist joke
but he basically never does like racial hierarchies, any sort
of uh race realism. He He keeps it entirely absent from his content.
I've never even seen like hints towards it, right?
Yes. Like I've never even seen hints at it. He would have if
it wouldn't tank his career. Nick Fuentes has ascended and he's
he all about it. So, openly even in this current day and age.
yeah, I do think Andrew is like pretty against it. So, usually
when Rachel makes these arguments, I'm going to like kind of
line up with my thoughts on Andrew and say, "This probably isn't
something to do with race, but it sure sounds like it does."
I'm going to let this play. I need to go grab some more water.
I will be 2
I'll be like 2 minutes. I'm going to let it play. >> you're
getting more in SNAP benefits and welfare than you're getting
in taxes, >> should be based on how much you pay in taxes
or if you pay taxes >> on whether you are contributing
to the system or not. If you're taking more than you're contributing,
no, you shouldn't be having a voice in governance. You should
also have to take a civics test proving that you have some rudimentary
understanding of how our government works. >> of people
wouldn't voted for Donald Trump if that was the case. But anyway,
so okay, so you don't think that women should be allowed to vote.
You don't think women should be allowed to vote at least if they're
Would you Would you like me to explain why? No. Do you know why
the birth rate is so low? No. No, he doesn't want me to explain
why. Well, well, I I find it I find it interesting that you want
to take away one of the most fundamental rights
of a woman,
which is being able to vote. By the way, women are as you I I
think you're aware bringing children into this world. Not enough.
Well, yeah. Why? Why is that? What's the number one reason why
women aren't bringing children in? Do you want to know like the
actual correlate? No, I want to know the polls of the last 2
years and women have asked cuz I have the studies right in front
of me right here. What is the number one reason, Rachel, why
women aren't bringing kids into this world in the last 2 years?
Do you know the reason for >> I can TELL YOU WHAT
OKAY, GUESSES? DO WE HAVE GUESSES?
I feel like it's going to be economic
I feel like that's going to be what it is. Like they're trying
to set them It's economic anxiety overall. That's got to be what
it is, right? You know what I'm
That's got to be it. >> data says. The data says that the
number one correlate to declining birth rates around the world
in every culture regardless of income or religion is women's
ac- This is going to just be urbanization and industrialization,
but she's going to say something else, but it's just going to
be urbanization and industrialization.
That's what it's going to be. access to higher education and
pushing them into >> Not true. So according to the John
Hopkins School of Public Health, which uh I've been polled for
the last 2 years, they've done it eight times, the John Hopkins
School of Public Health I'll take their word over yours. Uh they
say the number one reason why women don't want to bring children
into the world is Okay, hold on, hold on. So she said something
that is literally going to have all of the same
it's going to be the same graph as what I said, right? And what
I said, I'm confident that that's what it is. It's not women
getting the right to vote. I think you could have a society where
women don't have the right to vote and they have the right to
work and you would get the same thing. Now, if you want to take
away women's right to work somehow, that seems totally psychotic.
I have no idea. Like obviously it all seems psychotic, but at
least the suffrage thing it's like okay, they could still function
as humans with normal rights outside of that or something. Although
I guess without suffrage, how long would they operate that way,
right?
yeah, to me I'm just like it's just it's about the economy, it's
about urbanization. Not need not having the economic incentives
to have kids and then kids being increasingly expensive
>> they say the number one reason why women don't want
to bring children into the >> Come on. >> is something
called the economy, Rachel. Now, now let's talk a little bit
about the economy real quick. Hold on, hold on. Let's let's talk
a little bit about that. Let's talk a little bit about that,
Rachel. >> Okay. Why are people losing their medical coverage?
Why are people losing their food stamps? Is it because they're
just lazy and they don't want to work? Okay, so we're doing another
straw man argument because
>> Everything's a straw man argument. >> I'll explain
[laughter] how you're wrong. The only The only people who do
have uh replacement birth rates are the poorest people. So if
it was economics, we wouldn't see that the only people having
children would be the poorest among us and historically everybody
has had children during times of much much >> You're saying
the reason why is because poor people can't bring people in the
>> No, I'm saying listen very carefully and try to understand.
>> I'm listening. The poor people are the ones having the
babies. So the people who have the resources are opting out because
they think their job is more important, because they want to
take vacations, because they want to pay for a second vehicle
and they think they want to have kids. >> poor are polled
and they're saying that the reason why they're not having kids
is because of the economy. Are they lying God and that's the
reason why they don't have any kids? >> having stuff Right.
>> a career over having a family. >> should we do
about that? What do you think Do you think taking away health
care and and health care is the right >> that. I'll tell
you what what we should do about it is what I'm doing right now,
what Andrew does all the time, which is explain why atheism is
r-
why you shouldn't why you shouldn't hold to secular materialist
world views that have no grounding, that have no fundamental
basis for morality and I like I actually think you don't have
to say atheism is atheism
I think
Oh man, it's like I think there's something to be said for the
idea of family and the idea of how
like a religious world view seems to cause like how seems to
lead to happier outcomes in a lot of people and seems to like
lead to families this long-term fulfillment. There's like a map
to fulfillment there. That's something worth talking about. I
don't think it's like atheism inherently. It's just atheism got
rid of like there were a lot of very overt negatives to religiosity
for a lot of years and all of those negatives became very very
very clear to people and some people broke away. But there were
positives that you couldn't see because they were structural
and they kind of held up. It was almost like the the shadow of
these positives that pushed towards family, the community, the
third spaces. The shadow of these
persisted
without it there, right? And then over time it slowly dissipated
and nobody could really identify that it was basically the church,
you know, in in America like the church, Christianity that was
holding that up and now it's gone. The negatives were so loud
too. Yeah, like it's really hard to get away from the scandal
in the Catholic Church,
And there are a lot of other negatives
again, it was the the negatives were loud and the positives were
understated or unknown that it was just like that was the way
society functioned. But as you know, it's a combination I would
say of the the smartphone and the the decreasing religiosity
that people sort of lack meaning, they don't have a drive to
have some deeper meaning. And a lot of that was rooted in family.
I That's why I think the gender war stuff, all the gender split,
gender war stuff to me is super gross because
to me it's like it's totally fomenting a thing that's already
sort of under siege.
And that is basically I think finding like a partner and living
that way is more or less the way most people get happy in the
world.
So it seems bad. I agree with the Wilsons on that one. It's just
I don't think that it's a it's about attacking anybody. It should
just be like, "Hey, look at how happy some of these people are."
Seems like it's really it's like a really good way to live your
life is to have this this road map to meaning. And lead you into
deaths of despair and lead you into an anti-natalist position
where you won't >> Um I think the family stuff comes from
the religion more than the community. I think the community helps
with it and the community does help with fulfillment and and
long-term happiness, but I do think the religiosity does go hand
in hand with the family stuff.
Right? I don't think I don't think this happens that your kid
does something bad and you stop loving your kid. I don't think
that's real. >> You won't even reproduce yourself. >> think
you saying that makes you Uh so first of all, to use that word
and to call No, it's not cool for her to use that word. To say
that just because we don't believe in what you believe that people
are because Okay, good. Good. Good. Good. So let me be very Let
me be very clear, okay? Everybody has the
>> to believe in what they believe in. Everybody has the
right. You can be a Christian, you can be an atheist, to call
people
they don't believe in the religion that you believe in or they
don't believe in God is so beyond absurd and bigoted in nature.
It's ridiculous. It's No, I think you are.
so What I was going to say What I was going to say
going to say just be quiet. Make your Make Make Andrew a sandwich
and be quiet. So That's pretty misogynistic.
What? This guy is so bad at making any argument. What is this
guy doing? 20 million Andrew, do you have a cigarette cuz I need
one right now. Um so listen, uh listen. I want everybody Hold
on >> getting your butt whipped by a housewife. Yeah, yeah.
You're You're Yeah, you're kicking my butt, Rachel. Calling calling
everybody because they don't think like you is a wonderful argument
to make. So
20 million people in this country have lost their health care
because of what is in the big and beautiful bill. Millions of
people have lost their food stamps and while people that are
sitting over there think it's funny that people in this country
are struggling living paycheck to paycheck, many of those people
can't afford to have a child. And if they have multiple children,
they have to work two jobs. They have to work three jobs. Now,
what happens if a woman hasn't met the right man and she's in
her 30s? What does she do there? What happens if a woman is a
single woman trying to raise children? What is she supposed to
do to raise those children? You know, the people who you support
are against
I This is one part So this is he's he's trying to adopt manosphere
talking points and this doesn't work perfectly with the Wilsons.
And I I wish dude, Andrew could be so much more compelling to
me. I understand that for a broader audience Andrew wouldn't
be more compelling. But if he could genuinely commit to like
the forgiveness thing and be able to do that and not be a petty
spiteful person all the time, I would actually believe that they
they really follow this world view.
Like it's the lack of forgiveness from them that's the most telling
to me that
cuz all all Rachel's going to say here is, "We don't judge those
people. They can enter the church and they can be a part of it
and we totally bring them in." But then when they talk online
and they judge they they just they're so judgmental of everybody.
They don't let mistakes go from anybody,
And it's like bro, I could believe you guys if you're just a
little more forgiving, a little more compelling on that front.
Cuz that's what she's going to tell him and he's going to have
a hard time arguing against it cuz he won't have examples of
them not being forgiving at all, right?
benefits. They're against maternity leave and they're basically
against every government program that would help that mother
raise that child. These are the people that you support. So while
you can call people
for simply not agreeing with your religious beliefs, you're mocking
me for making arguments and yet you want to insult everybody
that disagrees with you. Let me be very clear. I support Wait,
hold on. 1 second. 10 seconds. Okay, at some point you will.
Finish the sandwich. So the point that I was trying to make was
I want everybody to believe in what you want to believe in. I'm
not going to call you
because you don't want to be Christian, because you don't want
to be By the way, I'm not an atheist. I do believe that there
is a higher power. I just don't consider myself an extremely
religious person. I would never call you all because you don't
believe in the same religion
that Rachel believes in. I don't live my life based on a book.
You can. I choose not to. That doesn't make me It doesn't make
you I know a lot of very intelligent people that do not believe
in God. It doesn't mean they're bad people. It doesn't mean they're
That is not an argument, Rachel. You're insulting millions and
millions of people in this country that don't believe in what
you believe in. Go ahead, Mr. [__] Go ahead. >> that
was yet another might land Well, she said first in in his defense,
Sophia. So, I see what you're saying that like it might land
better if he wasn't calling her
She said the the secular or the
uh atheistic materialist worldview is
And that describes him. And so, she did technically call him
first. another straw man ad hominem argument because, and I'll
explain why. Uh you know how long the birth rate has been below
replacement levels?
Any idea? I'm sorry, you asked me a >> Yes. What was the
question? How long have birth rates been below replacement >> by
the last 2 years according to the John Hopkins School of Public
Health. >> my question? How long have the birth rates been
below replacement? >> I The data I have are the last 2
years. >> Okay, he doesn't know. So, I'll tell you. It's
>> It's been for about 50 years. >> Okay. So, was
Trump to blame for the birth rate being below replacement in
the 1980s? >> say that. Okay, what caused it then? What
During the prosperity of the early '90s when we had one of the
best economies we've had? >> Why was the birth rate below
replacement >> Sure. Sure.
Um because the reason people don't have kids has nothing to do
with the reason they say they won't have kids. Polling people
on something like this is not Like that's the reason they basically
say they don't necessarily want kids or they're they're concerned
or waiting for kids. But realistically, that is not the actual
reason they're not having kids,
in my opinion.
So, I'll answer that, but I'll start by saying this. I I don't
know I don't know what's so funny. Um I have the study
for the last 2 years. Now, I didn't bring up the study for why
the birth rate was lower 50 years ago. Um and the reason why
I didn't is in my opening monologue what I told everybody
is that I care about what's going on in this country. Right >> your
point. My point disproves your >> you talking about? It's
the economy right now. Right now. >> You said the reason
women aren't having Yeah, you said the reason is I think basically
every economist agrees with why the birth birth rate goes down.
It's It's like nothing to do with what she's saying or what he's
saying.
It's that people operate based on forces they can't even see,
and we all know what the forces are. And why are we even like
complaining about it or talking about it in a way that isn't
Just It's literally urbanization. You don't have the space for
kids. You don't have the need for kids. You have a You have a
job that's just you. You don't have land. You don't need to work
it. You don't have to have kids in your home to take care of
you when you're older. Right? You don't need kids who can take
care of the other kids. There's so many incentives that are missing
that used to be there. And then, yes, in cities it is more expensive.
So, if you want to live a prosperous life, you go to a city.
Yes, exactly. It's why South Korea and Japan are so bad, Shimu.
As you get increasingly urbanized, you get disconnected from
these family ways of living. And that's precisely it. It just
proceeds the same way everywhere. That's how it is everywhere.
World population spiked massively in the last few hundred years.
Why not let the birth rate drop off for a bit and then level
off? I don't get it. Because you need a tax base, Private Huff.
You need You only have so many people that are within their tax-paying
years, okay?
And so, if you just stop having kids, if you have massive If
you have a massive cliff in kids, suddenly you don't have a tax
base anymore. That's why Canada imported like 10 million Indian
immigrants, okay? Cuz they're like, "Oh, we're about to not have
a generation of kids." We put off our population cliff for like
a decade and a half by importing so many people. Now, our society
might totally disintegrate because of a race war, but if it doesn't,
our economy will be okay in a way that a lot of other economies
won't. All right, we'll be able to keep our social safety nets
running. All right? But that's that's what I'm saying is you
need the tax base.
That's why Canada took a way different approach. That's fundamentally
why they took that approach was we saw the population cliff coming
that's coming after baby boomers for everybody, right? And Canada
was like, "Oh, that's going to be really bad if that hits." And
they decided to start importing a bunch of people. It kind of
just kicks the can down the road, but it gives it time to normalize
and for you to I guess get a chance to have automation kick in
and not really feel the effects all that
but it's just It's almost impossible to incentivize this through
the government. Cuz again, like I said, your way of life included
having kids before. It was like very very very necessary. And
that without the social pressure, without the economic pressure
to have kids,
there's basically like kid It turns out it's not really that
big a thing. is this. I'm telling you it's been this way for
50 years, so it can't Saving the GDP is worth a race war, I guess?
No. No, it's about being able to pay out so social security.
Like um Yeah, it's not social security in Canada. It's um
What the do we call it here? Why can't I Uh [screaming] Canada
It's not Canada pension. It is Canada pension, isn't it?
Yeah, it's Canada pension. Why didn't I remember that? I should
really remember that. Holy
But you have to be able to pay Old Age Security is different.
Canada Pension is social security, I think. You pay into it.
It's like your own payments in. Right? You need to be able to
pay out the entitlements in the country or pay for the services.
If you can't pay out the entitlements or for the services in
the country, your country disintegrates.
Yeah, CPP Canada Pension Plan. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's why Canada did it. It's not about GDP. Although, it could
also you could argue it's also about GDP. It was all done legally,
though.
Anyway, it's very important that you have a tax base. And basically,
there's like there's a threefold way you can do stuff, right?
You can do one of three things to deal with your diminishing
tax base because all of your best workers are retired. You can
raise the retirement age so those workers don't retire. You can
cut entitlements. You can cut Canada Pension. You can cut universal
health care. You can cut some of the government services. Or
you can increase taxes. Or
you can bring in immigrants to pay more. You need to get more
tax base. You can bring in immigrants who pay more in
Nobody will vote for raising entitlement ages. Nobody will vote
for anything like raising the retirement age. Nobody will vote
to get rid of services.
Nobody will vote to raise taxes.
And so, you're left with one thing. You essentially have one
thing left that's going to not destroy your country or that's
going to make you electable. And so, everybody's always like,
"Wait, why do you bring all these immigrants in even though nobody
likes it?" It's like, "CUZ WE'RE TRYING TO KEEP THE GOVERNMENT
GOD DAMN IT." CAN'T BE ANYTHING that's happened in the last 2
years. >> why women are not having children now. >> follow
logic? >> able to listen to logic? I just told you I just
told you right now the reason why women aren't having kids now.
Now, I know you care about 50 years ago. I care about 50 >> consistency
over time. >> right now, the number one reason is the economy.
That's what I'm trying to explain to you. Why don't you pay >> What I'm
trying to explain to you is that even in the '90s when when the
economy was at its best, women were still not having more than
two >> change, and people change, and and women have different
opinions of why they're doing different things. >> disproves
your theory. You can take a You can take one survey.
>> What you have is one survey. How many people were asked
the question in the >> Uh I have it right here.
18,000.
18,000? >> Yes, 18,000 at John Hopkins. Right. So, you
don't think that it could be the case that when they say it's
the economy, they're not saying we're starving. They're saying,
"Look, I want to go on a cruise every year. I want that second
vehicle. I want a higher standard of living, and >> Wait,
hold on. Let me Let me Let me Let So, the reason why women aren't
having kids is because they want to go on a cruise. That's not
what you're >> want a higher mate. It's a lot of things,
but I mean, he He's going to have a hard time
What How is Does he not realize that he made this argument essentially?
Does he not realize that he actually essentially made this argument
already?
That like economic concerns are why That there's just another
way of formulating it, right? That women have economic concerns,
it's why they don't want to have Okay, he's realizing now. >> of
living. And so, >> How do you know that? Well, you did
this big long monologue, so now I'm going to do one. Uh if you
know anything about the economics of last 50 years in the birth
rates, you would know that prior to pushing women into the workforce
in huge numbers in 1970, most women with school-age children
stayed at home. Overwhelmingly, there was only like 6% of kids
thinks economic concerns means you can't feed yourself and are
home homeless almost. I find economic concerns The funny thing
is is it's like the WASPy people who have economic concerns,
right? It's Dude, you never hear like a person who makes $30,000
a year and their spouse makes $30,000 a year, you never hear
them go, "Well, we can't have kids cuz we we make too little
money. We can't have any more." No, those people have 10 kids,
right? It's the people who are like, "I don't know if we'll be
able to definitely always be prosperous if we have kids right
now, so I'm not going to have kids." kids who uh had a mom that
worked full-time. During that time, the funda the economy fundamentally
changed into a two-income economy where rather than just having
the basics where a janitor who's a father of five can support
all those kids on one income, and they can have a house in a
nice neighborhood. They can have a car. They can afford groceries,
and they can even afford to retire. Imagine such a thing. Like
the baby boomers did. When we pushed women into the economy in
huge numbers, it did a couple of things. The first is it created
that two-income trap where now you don't have a family wage,
you have an individual wage. And on top of that, we changed from
being uh Women are just God's illegal immigrants, okay? That's
how I But that's how I like to feel or think about it, okay?
When they decided to put women in the economy, they just introduced
a bunch of labor. All right? It only favored
the capital owners. It was [__] up.
It was [__] up, okay? Dude, I Hold on. Isn't the
argument here man I Oh, I'm getting like black billed suddenly.
Isn't the argument that you needed more wars? That as long as
there were men going to war, you always had women who needed
to work and that was fine and wages didn't go down and everything
was
And then America stopped having wars and suddenly all the men
started to accumulate Bro, was Liv right all along? When Liv
said we need another war, we need all the men to die. a more
of a productive economy to what uh my friend Aaron Clarey calls
a she-economy. And this is more of a service-based,
Oh, we do that. Oh, no. >> debt-based economy where everybody
is buying more than they can afford. They are financing everything.
They are living well above their means and it takes two incomes
to keep this up. And this happened because we gave women a ton
of uh free college. It wasn't really free. They had to pay it
back. Women are now the majority debt holders. They have the
most degrees, but they also go into life with an average of $50,000
in debt. So, yes. I'm not done yet. So, yes, when you have a
young woman who spends all of her formative years going to school,
she doesn't graduate college till she's at least 22, maybe later.
She's got $50,000 in debt starting out and she has to start a
career, of course she's going to say, "I can't have a baby. I
I just started in life with debt and a career that I have to
build, otherwise all this college I went to is for nothing."
That's why I chose not to do it cuz I wanted to have a family
and I thought it doesn't make The way The way that
you win this and it's difficult against Rachel cuz I don't know
what she argues for on the other side, right? The way you argue
against this is basically saying like I'm totally fine. If you
want to say that this is the argument you want to actually like
somehow get kids more involved or get You need to make it like
ironclad divorce laws. Like Like literally women get automatically
50%. Women are totally taken care of if they get divorced. Like
if you want to start making sure that when women decide to opt
out of the economy, they're completely taken care of. If that's
what you want to do, then sure, women can go and have kids. Like
that's That's where you need to argue. Now, Andrew looks like
a giga hypocrite on this cuz he'll always do the Well, men are
the true victims and men get divorced and men are always in trouble,
But basically, if you're not willing to stand up and have your
career in the economy as a woman right now, then you could be
throwing your life away. And you have no idea what you're going
to do with that, right? Like you have no idea if you just throw
away your your delay your career for two, three, four years,
you're set you're setting yourself up to face like major, I don't
know, you're you're you're setting yourself up for major hurdles.
It's a huge problem. So, you'd have to incentivize women to be
willing to risk
And until you can take care of those concerns, which you could
if you wanted
I I think Like Rachel's not entirely wrong. The double income,
you know, household, the two-income household or even, you know,
just the fact that you can have at-fault or no-fault divorce
and you can break up and potentially be in a situation where
you have to take care of yourself. That's forcing women to go
and actually make sure that they can take care of themselves.
You'd never advocate for a man to get married and like just stay
at home, right? What would you think of a man who who got married
and just stayed at home? And well, I think the Christian worldview,
that would not be within your role, right? And a lot of women
want to do that and feel the social pressure that they cannot
make that choice because everyone around them goes, "You've got
to have your own money. You This is I This could be This could
be the social pressure. This This could be
But I do think I wish there was less of this. I wish there was
more encouraging of women. I wish there was more of a safety
net, too, for them. But I wish there's more encouraging women
to just be able to go and have families. I do feel like online
there's a little bit of that, like kind of
you know, younger moms.
And even from their friend groups and stuff. I just don't think
it makes any sense. It's not very cool. >> Well, you can't
depend on a man. That's scary. He'll abuse you and you'll have
to leave and it's going to be awful and we don't fearmonger women
about Let's say a woman wants to be a dentist and we say, "Well,
what happens if you get arthritis? What if you hurt your hand
or lose your fingers in an accident?"
Are you suggesting welfare queens right now? Are you suggesting
we put welfare queens into policy, evil Johnny Bravo? You want
welfare queens, man? That's crazy. Excuse me. >> You can't
rely on being a dentist. What if something happens? All right.
Technically, I'm in Canada, but also this is America. It's not
that just to summarize, it's not that women are too poor. It's
not that people are too poor. We still have a much higher standard
of living than we've ever had historically. It's not that we
can't afford children. It's that we fundamentally trans I think
it would be fine, in my opinion,
Oh, man, no, it wouldn't. I don't know. I want to argue for something
crazy like the fact that Wouldn't you be fine just paying an
extra tax? You just add an extra tax to everything where you
actually have to pay a little bit more. You have to pay a little
bit in. If
you're a man.
>> You You just you're you're societally paying in for
women to have some form of like security, some sort of like childcare
help there. That like benefits them. And maybe as long as you're
living in the same household, you get to opt out of that. But
if you're a single man who's not currently like married or has
kids, you have to pay this tax in. Oh my god, did we just tax
the incels? Am I arguing to tax the incels? Oh my god. If
If I wasn't getting, you know, I watched that Sleepy video earlier.
If I wasn't getting killed because of Destiny calling for my
death, if I if I argue to tax the incels, I'm I'm done, man.
Oh, boy. That'll be scary. the economics of the country and people
have different material standards that they want instead that
they prioritize over family. >> Okay, so I just uh repeat.
She just said It's not that women can't afford children. Rachel's
in a a situation where she has means and she has money. She doesn't
speak for all the other women that were in this John Hopkins
uh where they all said that the number one reason was the economy.
There could be all sorts of different reasons. I don't believe
that the majority
of these women said they're not having kids because they want
to be able to go on a cruise, okay? I I don't believe I'm not
done yet, okay? I don't believe that at all. She's making a gross
assumption in assuming to to form her argument that all these
women are not having kids and it's got nothing to do with any
of the policies put forth right now. It's got nothing to do with
the fact Well, it's got it's something to do with the policies
put forth, but you're both arguing it's the policies. She's arguing
it's different >> living to paycheck to paycheck or they're
single mothers who can't get maternity leave. It's got nothing
to do with any of that stuff. Yeah, I think you kind of get cooked
by You get kind of get cooked by Rachel on the Well, the poorest
people are having the most kids argument, right? It's really
not It's not really the single moms and probably the reason the
studies might not show that, maybe. When you ask women, they're
like, "Oh, it's economic concerns." That makes you think it'd
be all the poor people. But it's probably just a sampling bias
on WASPy types, right?
But it's, you know, forming her argument on that, which I which
obviously I I I completely disagree. But she said something very
interesting.
It's the whole form of of of why I'm here today. She said she
chose.
She chose to do things in her life and I would never want to
take that away from you, Rachel. But you want to take that away
from other people. And then you'll say, "That's a straw man argument."
You've said in this debate thus far, what are we halfway through?
That she doesn't believe
that the majority of women should vote. She thinks it should
be on a level of >> should vote, either. >> Okay.
Okay. Well, well, that's that's a great argument, [laughter]
Rachel. That's a great argument. Um It is a great argument. Then
why is the birth rate going down,
Uh I mean, it's going down across the board. I'm saying it makes
you think that it's the poorest people who have the concerns.
It's not necessarily. >> So, you don't believe women should
vote and you don't believe a certain percentage of men should
vote. But everybody should be allowed to have a gun though, right?
If you're not a >> Yes, exactly. >> Right? Right?
That That makes a lot of >> That makes a lot of sense.
I think the founders were correct about >> Wait, what?
What?
>> Why is he Is he like, "Okay, I lost this. Let's turn
this into a gun control debate. Okay, we're pivoting to gun control.
We can win on gun control. I know my talking points. Let's go."
>> had muskets, Rachel. We have AR-15s now. >> What does
that have to do with something? That's a lot to do with WITH
WHAT WITH GUN CONTROL. >> This is a guy who's never shot
a musket because if he thinks muskets I I'm a firearms instructor,
by the way. If he thinks muskets are less dangerous >> you
guys to think about that for a Hold on, Rachel. Calm down. Don't
freak out. Calm down. So, the bottom line here is she wants to
take away the rights of >> your guns. He wants to take
away your guns, right? >> don't. No, I don't. NO, I DON'T.
>> DON'T YOU LET HIM TAKE AWAY YOUR RIGHTS. NO, I don't.
By the way, the people laughing right there, that's the Andrew
Wilson circle right over there.
>> NOT ANYMORE.
ANDREW'S LIKE cackling at him. Andrew's cackling at him and now
he's uh now he's losing it on the crowd. Uh-oh. It's not good
when you start fighting with the crowd, man. Comedians can tell
you this, but also lesser-known fact, not good for debaters,
either, if you're going to fight the crowd, man.
So, I don't want to take away anybody See, she's wrong. I don't
want to take away anybody's right to own a gun as long as they're
not a felon. I've never said that. By the way, as far as I know,
>> did you throw that at me? LIKE, "OH, YOU WANT EVERYONE
TO HAVE GUNS." I'LL TELL YOU WHY. I'LL TELL you why. Because
of how ridiculous her argument is. Oh, I can't wait. >> away
the rights
of people to vote, but yet those same people that are not, as
you said, contributing to society, go ahead and buy 10 guns and
thousands of rounds of ammunition. I don't want to take your
right away, no matter how smart you are or how stupid you might
be or how much money you're paying in taxes. I don't want to
take your rights away. I'm I'm pro First Amendment. I'm Listen,
I've never said that I want to take all of your guns away. And
by the way, I can't think of one elected official on the left
that said that either. Not that this is a gun control debate.
I don't want to I don't want to I don't want to take your right
away to vote either. Listen, I get frustrated sometimes and I
say, "Man, I wish stupid people weren't allowed to vote. Man,
I wish those people weren't allowed to vote." But would I want
to put a law in place to take that right away from you? Of course
not. Maybe I could agree with some sort of basic I know I had
a conversation with Vivek Ramaswamy about this and I sort of
agree with him that if you had some sort of basic civics test
or something, I can't say I would be against that. Maybe we agree
on that. But but the fundamental Why did he pick Why did he pick
Vivek there? I do Of all the people you could say you agree with,
why in the world would you pick Vivek Ramaswamy? If you're not
If you're not making enough money or you're unemployed or you're
poor, that that should be a factor in whether you should vote
or not. I completely fundamentally disagree with that. Okay.
So, you think that people who take from the treasury and raid
the treasury, take the tax money of those who are producing,
should be allowed to vote in huge numbers to take more from those
people? >> specific. You're talking about welfare, food
stamps? >> talking about anyone who takes I'm not saying
poor people. I was poor most of my life. So, most of your life
you shouldn't be allowed You shouldn't have been allowed to vote
then. >> Dude, what is wrong with this guy?
How Like I He's not even Dude, the arguments are easy. This guy's
just like way too energetic.
He's just got way too much heat, man. >> taking more from
the system than I was getting. So, if you're on SNAP benefits
or on TANF, you're getting Medicaid, you're taking tens to maybe
hundreds of thousands from the government in subsidies and welfare,
then no, you don't get to vote to continually steal from other
people. >> people that steal billions of dollars? Should
they be allowed to vote?
They should go to prison if you can prove that. >> a full
pardon? Should they be allowed to >> Well, if you get a
pardon, that's the legal system. What do you want me to do about
that? So so if you're So hold on, hold on. So So if you're somebody
that has stolen
billions of dollars
and you get a pardon,
you should be allowed to vote. But if you're somebody
that is struggling, maybe living paycheck to paycheck, maybe
doesn't have a job, maybe doesn't have the opportunities that
some other people
you shouldn't be allowed to vote. >> but it's absurd. It's
absurd. >> question here. So,
Hey, he's not even
Like could you make a Dude, the argument's not even hard. Maybe
maybe I'm just not paying attention. I'm starting to tune him
out a little bit. Maybe I'm not paying attention. The argument
is, "Hey, if you don't get If you don't have the right to vote
when you are not a next net taxpayer, then technically your rights
can be taken away. You're already put behind in society, right?"
This is the
Oh, what is this? This is the Australia brought this up when
she was talking to Hutch. It's the Rawlsian shroud of ignorance
thought experiment, right? That's That's what this is right here.
Uh thank you for the raid, Dickers. Like basically, imagine you
could design a society and you get to you you're told basically
you can define like the classes in that society and what class
you get to belong to or even Yeah, basically what class you you
could possibly belong to, but you need to design the society
in such a way so that no matter what class you're put into, you're
okay with that society existing the way it is. Right? That's
That's basically like when it comes down to, "Okay, these people
don't pay in. They're like basically economically
Would you want to be somebody who is already like economically
destroyed and doesn't have the right to vote and can never change
their circumstances through the government?"
Like no, that is obviously the path towards just getting further
and further away from ever having a prosperous life,
So, you you don't want that. It's like obviously these people
already set behind. Probably everybody's got some inherent idea
of fairness, right? Some idea that like, "Hey, as you get further
behind, there should be some sort of rubber banding that lets
you catch up a little bit. Nobody should be like kicked down
and destroyed."
And if you take away the right to vote of the people who are
the most trod the the lowest in society, then they're never going
to get up from that again. And so you would never design that
in in the shroud of ignorance, you'd never design that because
you might be put in that rung and then you would be
You know what I'm saying?
That's That's the whole point of that experiment is how how would
you design the society so that no matter what rung you end up
in, you you would you understand you're going to be put into
one of these randomly
and where are you going to want to be? That's how you have to
decide the society, right? So, obviously the idea of mobility,
the idea that you're not totally destroyed or or stuck if you're
in the lowest Yeah, veil of ignorance, yep. Yep, yep, yep.
Yep. Um that's the whole point, right?
And so that's the argument you make back is basically that same
thing that you don't want people who are just destroyed, who
are like eternally You don't want some lower caste in your society
that can never ever make their way back. I'll make a deal with
you. I'll say all the women can vote No, I will not have a beer
with your husband. What? What the [__] is this guy
saying?
What? This He's so broken.
>> Okay. You know what? I'm actually Now I'm psyched that
we did this cuz this is actually way better content than I thought.
I'm It's too bad I was a little distracted earlier. I was like
sending a couple messages. It's still been great, but I That
Dude, now I'm listening and this guy is losing it.
This guy's totally lost it.
I need to start going around to people people's houses and taking
their soundboards by force.
>> I'll my soundboard out of my cold dead hands, man. Never
ever ever. >> Nobody wants to have a beer with you, >> Thank
you. Thank you. Thank you. All the women All the women can vote
if they have to sign up for the draft when they turn 18 like
the >> Let's talk about the draft. I'm happy to do that
with you. Okay. So, here's my opinion on the draft, right? And
here's my opinion on women and I'm glad you brought that up.
I believe that there should be a basic physical standard that
both men and women need to Oh, so boring, man. >> pass.
And if because Well, I think we all could agree in this room
on average, right? A man is physically stronger than a woman
on average. That doesn't mean that there aren't women out there
that are pretty strong. So, my opinion is is is pretty simple
on this. If you can pass that basic There aren't women out there
who are particularly strong in terms of upper body strength.
I'm sorry to tell you
Ryan. I'm sorry to tell you I Listen, if there It doesn't mean
they can't be drafted, but I don't know why you're saying there
should be a physical test. No, there should be two different
tracks. You should have like a logistics track and a deployment
track. And unfortunately, women are not going to be strong enough
to go into combat in a lot of different areas. That's just facts.
No, not without juice. Bro, show me women benching two plates.
They're like the If women bench two plates, they are like the
99.99999th
It's just not the case. It's very difficult for them. It's not
that they can't, although I think two plates Is two plates not
like getting right up there with like non-juiced like highest
world records? I feel like it is.
There are men with weak grip strength and they're caught out.
They're gone. basic physical It's just a code word. It's like,
"I can't say women suck at something." Yes, you can. The average
dude benches with the average woman squats. Yeah, pretty much.
And women can build up lower body strength. Women can move stuff
around. Women can carry Women can do all that, but just in terms
of upper body strength, which you need in some various combat
roles to like move people, move bodies and stuff, right? Like
if your buddy gets knocked out, women have a very hard time like
doing any sort of lift, doing Sorry, like the requiring the the
strength to like get this the dead weight moved.
And it's not like a bad thing. It just is what it is, dude. >> standard
that a man and a woman would have to pass.
He said women who could do that. I know he said women who could
do that, but he's like because a lot of women are really strong.
No, if you have the same standards and and you're not lowering
them for everybody, then a lot of women are going to fail that.
It's going to mostly be men. So, you don't even you don't even
fix it. It's just that women would be drafted in a non-combat
roles.
And that's unfair, but it is what it is. Yes, two plates is not
Two plates is not a lot. Like any guy who does any amount of
training, if they have any normal amount of testosterone production,
they will hit two plates, okay? And they're willing to risk their
life for this >> about voluntary service. No one is No
one is barring women from the military, dude. We're talking about
>> difference? Should women be able to go to war? Should
Should women be able to be there? I asked you a question about
the draft. Let's stick to my question rather than switching.
I think that if women want the same rights as men, they should
have to If we want equality, let's have equality. I'll believe
women want equality when they demand to sign up for the selective
service, when they demand to be part of the industries where
92% of the workplace deaths are compromised by men, when they're
doing 90% of the essential in Bro, if we if there's ever a draft,
if there's like a World War and there is a
women aren't going to get a choice. I'm sorry, you're getting
drafted.
You You have had an egalitarian society for the past like 40
years. If there's a draft, women are getting drafted. I If anybody
thinks that it's going to be a men-only draft, you're out of
your mind. That will go to the Supreme Court and it will be over
in 2 seconds.
infrastructure work Equal protections clause? Excuse me. Excuse
me, we need some of that D I We need some of that equal protections,
buddy. Hey, Mr. Alito, can we get some equal equal protections
over here?
No, wrong. You think so, Fran? I don't think so.
I'd bet any amount of money, but obviously we'd be in a big we
have a problem if we got there. That's equality. Equality is
not a system where men do everything dirty, dangerous, and difficult.
They die for the country. They die on the job. They die to defend
the borders. And women >> since the early '70s? >> Oh,
I'm glad that you asked. Not nearly as many as men. >> Hm,
let me see if I have it in my notes. It's a very small number.
You think over 30,000 people is a very small number? I That's
not what I had here. >> I have. Since the early '70s, over
>> Oh, since the early '70s, okay. How many men have died
in workplace jobs since the early '70s? >> I don't have
those stats in front of me. I imagine a A of men have died in
in workplace jobs since the early >> in combat by far.
I don't deny that. >> combine wars, so we're talking about
voluntary versus involuntary. Nobody is forcing men Nobody is
forcing men to have children. We are forcing men to sign up for
the draft, and we are forcing men to do everything that makes
this these lights, this live stream, these microphones possible.
Women do not build and maintain society. Haha, I hate this one
I hate this one. I hate this one. I hate this one.
There's nothing that says they can't. They just haven't because
they haven't had the opportunity.
They've only been in the workforce for so long, okay?
It takes a long time to build up like It just takes a long time.
Wait until there are more women CEOs, and we'll be able to decide,
okay? Forcing men to do this? Yeah, it's this whole thing where
they're like men built society, therefore men were forced to
build everything to make us happy. I don't know. It's like a
whole
It's a whole tradition argument, right? It's a traditional argument.
So So because Oh, it's I Do I call it a return to tradition argument?
It's like a fetishization of tradition argument. Women aren't
forced to have kids. You don't think that's a sacrifice when
they do Elle She is 96% confident that the Supreme Court would
force women to join the draft. Yeah, I'm pretty confident
women would be forced to. France said no, but I'm pretty confident
they would be forced to They wouldn't be forced to go and fight.
Right? Or they I I mean as unless you got to a drastic situation.
I assume they'd mostly be put into non-combat roles, or as much
as could be done. And then the ones who were really well really
in shape, they could maybe go and fight. do have kids when they
make that decision. When a man signs up for Mhm. uh voluntary
military service, yes, he is choosing to sacrifice. We commend
>> came home in caskets from Iran. You're aware of that.
>> who volunteers for either childbirth or military service
and dies is doing a great selfless thing. That's not what we're
talking about, buddy. You got to try to stick with the argument.
We're talking about what men are compelled to do and what What
are women compelled to do on behalf of society that might kill
>> Um you know, I don't think women are forced per se to
do anything, but what you are making the argument with us today
is you're making the argument that women should be at home and
be stay-at-home mothers, and they shouldn't be out there in the
workplace. >> Did I say that? Uh so tell me that then.
If Tell me your opinion on women in the workplace. Do you believe
that women should have the same opportunities as men in the workplace?
>> Yes, and they do. But what I will say Yes, they do,
obviously. What's the average pay for a woman and a man with
the same job? >> The wage gap reduces to about 3% when
you take into account the the fact that women choose easier,
lower-paying jobs, easier, lower-paying degrees than men on average,
and take much more time off and much more time away from work.
>> See this is the problem with this >> you're skipping
ahead, and you didn't let me finish the point here. We're talking
about
wage gap also I think disappears entirely with newer generations,
as far as I know. >> how men are forced and compelled to
possibly go to war and die, and we have no such responsibility
for women. No one's forcing women to do anything to defend the
country. No one's forcing women to go work a job that could kill
>> We don't have a civil We don't have civilization without
women uh bearing
I I recognize the arguments now. Pearl made these same arguments.
Rachel is far better at them, but Pearl made these same arguments,
which she was debating Atticus Ryan. You guys remember that one?
I feel like I'm about to hear how men are forced to get all of
the crab. Men have to go get the crab, and the crab The crabbers
are the It's the most dangerous job in the world to be a crabber,
okay? To get Arctic crab. Men are forced to, and that's why we
should respect men. >> that they're not I understand that
they're not Why are they Why are they Why do men have to sign
up for selective service at age 18? Or do you know what happens
to them if they don't? They get in big trouble, don't they? And
they lose rights, don't they? >> As I said earlier, women,
as a as a whole, are not as physically enabled as men, on average.
On average. That is why I said, and I'll repeat it again, I wouldn't
have a problem with that if they both passed the same physical
standard. >> You're not addressing my question. >> I'm
completely
I don't know why he thinks the draft is just for combatants.
It's really not. >> In fact, I would argue with like the
advent of drones and everything, you're going to need way more
non-combatants, non like Marines, non like army
soldiers as you would before, right? Like we're moving towards
an age of not having like human combatants anywhere near as much.
You will still have human combatants, but it's not going to be
the same thing. And so like it's probably a problem that just
solves itself. your question. I never said that. Although god
damn, women as drone drivers, uh-oh.
Women have to sign up for pass a physical test to sign up for
the draft. You know what I'm saying? >> I never made that
claim. >> So we're talking about the draft. Stick to the
draft. >> I I understand what we are talking >> about
when people go sign up for military I'm sorry, there's one thing
I This is one thing I'll always hold to my misogyny on until
there is a woman in a top like five Counter-Strike team, or a
top five any like Twitch reaction time game, any hand-eye coordination
game. They have to be top five team, a main participant, main
roster,
assigned female at birth. As soon as that happens, I will believe
you guys are on the same level in terms of those those uh exercises,
okay? Who cares?
I care. It's the one piece of misogyny I retain, Sophia.
And I I I need to hold on to it, okay?
You're not in a high-level CS team? Yeah, but I was. This It's
a statistics argument. I serve I'm going to boot camp. I'm not
talking about that. Well, that's the argument that I'm making.
I'm making it because you're That doesn't address the question.
The question is If men and women are equal, if men and women
are equal, why Okay, okay, all right. Okay, so so Didn't Ninu
smoke you? No, I beat Ninu.
What are you talking about? I beat Ninu. I haven't never played
my first time ever opening Counter-Strike, by the way.
First time ever. I beat Ninu first time ever. No practice, no
nothing. Very easy. Very, very easy. Sorry, I meant Counter-Strike
um Is it Global Offensive that's out now? No, CS2. My first time
in CS2. I'd played one of the earlier Counter-Strikes, obviously.
>> men and women are equal. As I've said before, there
are attributes that women have that are stronger than men. There
are attributes that men have that are stronger than men. I never
said as a whole that every job men and women are equal. I'm not
making that argument. The argument of this entire debate here
is the point that I'm trying to make is that I don't want to
Now Now to make that up to you, Sophia, I will say men and women
should be treated as equal. Like women should never be restricted
from having any opportunity.
Like I I hope we all understand that we've all watched an after-school
special where somebody's told that they're not allowed to do
something, like a woman or a black kid told, "Hey, you don't
get to do that." And then you get to watch the movie as they
go and they do it and they come over overcome the barriers. I'd
like to not have to have that movie. I'd like for people to just
be like, "Okay, you can try. Okay, we're supporting you."
You know what I'm saying? This guy's been up for 14 years. I
Dude, I don't play Counter-Strike. I don't care about Valve games.
Valve sucks. Valve. I interfere in other people's Valve Valve
Valve Valve is a [__] company. Gabe Newell is a demon,
okay? And you've all been fooled into thinking he's this nice,
kind guy, and he's not. He's a piece of [__]
>> That's really cute. That's so virtuous of you. It has
nothing to do with >> Well, I think it has I don't want
to tell anyone what to do. She doesn't want women to vote. She
thinks women should be second-class citizens. Tell me you haven't
said that. I have not said that women should be second-class
You've never said that in any debate on the He's too angry to
catch up where she's being weaselly. HE'S SHE'S SAYING WOMEN
SHOULDN'T HAVE THE right to vote, so they'll be second-class
citizens. She goes, "I've never said they'd be second-class citizens."
You think I've said women should be second-class citizens? >> said
that? No. Maybe it's a joke. >> Oh, maybe it's a joke.
I say a lot of stuff. It was just a joke. It was locker room
talk. Tell me when I said that. But like she has said women shouldn't
have the right to vote, or women are less happy with the right
to vote. She's absolutely said that. But he's too angry to even
pick up how she's being weaselly in that situation. I heard you
in a debate say that you you said women should be second-class
Now, you're saying you were joking? I don't ever remember saying
women should be second-class You don't remember. Okay. You know
what debate was it? >> I think that's interesting. I think
you're lying. What debate was I think you're lying. What debate
was it? >> Was it a joke? Who was I debating? I'll look
it up. Was it a joke? You're lying. I didn't say that. As When
I was doing >> proof or not? When I was doing debate >> have
proof or not? I will provide you the proof. Okay. So you're saying
you've never said that. No, I never said that. Okay. Okay. Okay.
Okay. >> So back to the draft. Why is it that men have
to sign up for the selective
or risk losing their voting rights and even their freedom, but
women don't? Why? Well, I just gave you the answer. As a whole,
in general, >> and women are different. >> When did
I say that they were exactly the same? That would be a little
bit ridiculous thing. I never said that. Why should women have
the exact same political power as men when, as the anti-suffrage
women brilliantly argued, they said, "Look, the purpose of government
is to protect persons and property. That's the function of argument
is because when we're born When we're born, as on on average,
as I've said, men might be on average stronger than women because
of that premise, and they have to sign up, women shouldn't be
allowed to vote. I completely disagree with that premise. >> Why?
Why? It's because >> I haven't heard an argument. I've
just heard you go, "I can't believe what she said. Can you hear
believe what she's saying? Oh, people are weird. She said women
should be second-class citizens. I think I think I think I think
I think I And you're [__] That's my impersonation
of >> should give me an argument. >> Okay, well,
bad impersonation, okay? Bad
I don't have a stupid hat.
Okay. All right. Now give me the argument, please. Do Do you
really want to go there? I want you to give >> physical
attributes? >> you to give me >> Is that what you're
going to >> mean, do you want
>> Wait, is he saying personal physical attributes because
she made fun of his hat? Wait, or did she call him bald or something?
Maybe I missed it. That's my impersonation of >> should
give me an argument. Okay, well, bad impersonation, okay? Bad
I I don't have a stupid hat. >> Bad impersonation.
>> Okay. All right. He did. He did. >> Now give me
the argument, please. Do Do you really want to go there? I want
you to give me an argument. >> physical attributes? >> you
to I know exactly He's going to say she's an ugly, fat [__]
or something. He That's where he wants to go right now, and she
just made fun of your hat. It's not a personal physical attribute.
That hat is not inherent. You picked that hat. That hat, not
unlike
Kanye's opinion on slavery, was a It was a choice for you. Do
not You don't get to escape blame. What the [__]
to give me an argument. >> what you're going to do? >> I mean,
do you want to have a modeling contest, Brian? I don't think
you're going to win. Okay, [laughter] I don't think you're going
to win, either. Fair enough. Now give me an argument. Tell me
why Tell me how we're supposed to have equality between the when
one is expected to die on behalf of Okay, tell She She did just
by the way, she just inferred that he was trying to call her
ugly, and she ran with it, and he didn't say, "No, I wasn't trying
to do that." That wasn't what he was trying to do. She made fun
of his hat, and he was like, "Yeah, well, you're an ugly I tried
to explain this to you, okay? Women have certain things that
they are better than men at. Women have certain responsibilities,
like bearing children if they decide to have children. The argument
that you're making is, "Well, it's a choice for a woman to have
a child." Okay, yes, it is a choice. I understand that. But still,
my point being is that just because women don't have to sign
up for the draft shouldn't be a reasoning why women should not
be allowed to vote. Let me ask you I'm going You go >> the
position. You did not give me an >> me ask you a question.
>> Why? What would be the difference? >> Because
women don't have to sign up for the draft. I know. Look here.
Look here. Listen for a second. >> He's so handsome. I
can't help it. I know. By the way, this is I I want to go on
a >> way. [laughter] I want to take a break and look this
way.
I will say this. Since Since you want to get Since you want to
get Since you want to get personal with me because she's been
doing that >> Cuz she's just making fun of your hat.
I HOW IS THAT GETTING HOW IS THAT LIKE SO [__] UP?
Does this guy wear that hat as much as Tim Pool wears his beanie?
Is that hat like intrinsically linked to his identity now? It's
just a hat, guy. What are you so mad about? >> give an
argument. He All he just did by
Wait, was he Was he Oh, he was Oh, no.
Hold on. Brian
Shapiro. Brian Shapiro. Oh, bro, he wore his hat everywhere.
Yeah, the hat is a part of his identity. Okay, never mind. That
hat is a part of him. And it's like Tim Pool. HE'S JUST LIKE
TIM POOL. BRO, WHAT'S up with bald guys just not willing to Like,
come on, man. >> You just restated the position. You're
You're insulting my physical appearance. You call people who
don't agree with you. And then you're talking to me about forming
an argument. You've called millions of people that don't agree
with you. And now Well, how does he virtue signal over this when
he showed up? The first thing he argued was she was a dumb who
doesn't realize that she's arguing against her own interests.
This stupid [__] has got like eight baby daddies.
And then there's just Yeah, he just doesn't get it that he's
He just doesn't get it. I Now he's like, "Oh, she's really mean,
too." >> You're talking about how handsome your husband
is. You couldn't be more insecure. He's so handsome. >> say
this, though. The other day when we had our little kind of Dude,
she's
He's He's tilted off the face of the earth. She won entirely.
She won She's literally saying Andrew Wilson is cute, and she's
winning. I will never forgive this guy. This is a travesty. This
is a crime against debate. This is a total It's a debate war
crime, okay? This is disgusting. >> funny. We had our little
Twitter spat. She spent all day trying to convince strangers
how hot her husband was.
You had to drop a hard R. A big one. LITTLE STRANGE LOOK AT HIM.
YEAH. LITTLE STRANGE. LISTEN, I think if you're in a healthy
relationship, you should think your husband is hot. If you're
married to a woman, you should think your wife is hot. I just
think it's a little weird trying to explain to thousands of complete
strangers, trying to convince them that your husband is hot.
I know it's a little weird. >> than you No, rather than
you you restating your position of I just don't think so. Tell
me why I told you over and over. No, I told you You're not Rachel,
you're not listening. Rachel, you're not listening. >> You're
not thinking. >> No, I'm thinking you're not listening,
>> Simply restating the position is not an >> I'm
not stating the position. I'm giving my opinion on what we are
discussing. I've already tried. You're not paying attention.
So, I'll say it again, okay?
Good. Now, like I do think she's starting to sound correct with
with her characterization that he's not making arguments. Like
he is just saying, "I think you're evil." And she's like, "Why?"
And he's like, "Well, because you call people It's like, "Well,
that happened after the debate. Why do you think feminism is
Do you understand that Without feminism, you'd be stuck in abusive
relationships?
Okay. I Could you make He made one societal argument. It was
What was it? Economic concerns, right? Based on a study. That
was it. >> no question that there are sacrifices that men
have to make that women don't have to make, like being in the
draft. I agree with you, okay? However, there are sacrifices
that women have to make that like bearing children and being
pregnant and having kids. I never said that I never said they
had to do it. >> error. I never said they had to do it.
Let me help this man with another logical fallacy. It's called
a category error. We are talking about a an involuntary thing
which people are compelled by the government to do versus a completely
voluntary >> going to have to agree to disagree. We're
going to have to agree to disagree. Do you think women are bad
in the government? Do you think they're bad representing in the
in government because you said that in your book, right? You
think This guy's like got quotes from Rachel. He's just going
to pull them up when he's losing. Well, I I think you said women
suck IN GOVERNMENT. WOMEN CAN'T BE POLITICIANS, according to
you, right? Gets blown out. Women can't even do this, according
to you, Rachel. >> think women should be in politics, no.
But you still haven't given me an argument for >> Well,
I I mean, we can beat a dead horse, but I'd like to move on to
another topic. You think You think women are bad No, because
we only How much time do we have left in this debate?
There's a lot of other things that we should be discussing. Yeah.
Yeah, exactly. 10 minutes more. You think women are bad in government,
right? You don't think they should be in government. You don't
think they should be politicians, right? Why is that? Why do
you think that way? >> Because the purpose of government
is for the protection of people and property, and women are not
able to accomplish that. Women There's a reason, by the way,
that historically women couldn't own property. It's because they
can't defend it. So, as a woman, if I owned like 100 acres of
land in 1845, how am I going to protect it from bandits, from
marauders, from people who wanted to come and take my land? I
would need You asked me a question, so I'm answering. I would
need men to do that on my behalf. I think the reason that we
shouldn't have women in government is because men are the only
people who can defend the borders, who can enforce the law. We've
seen what happens when you try to put female law enforcement
officers on the streets and on the border. It doesn't work out
very well. We need men, and we rely on them to protect persons
and
He He kind of just lets that one go. I'll be honest with you
guys. I don't know how to defend
like a lot of female law enforcement officers. It's not cuz they
all suck. It's that very often, if I'm watching I am I am a victim
of confirmation bias, okay? If I am watching a video on the internet
and there's a female officer in it, there's like an 80% chance
that she's shooting somebody in that video, okay? Just like automatically
on the surface. And that's my fault. I am a victim of confirmation
bias. I admit it, Stop watching those videos? I should. I should.
I'm just saying, that's what happens. I can't do it.
That is a part of it. Yeah, there's a physical strength argument
there. Yeah, sure that that Basically, the gun is how they defend
themselves. Sure. Applies to fat male officers, too.
>> Not as much. No. That's the That's the task of men to
protect. >> Let's talk about COVID for a moment. Female
Female leaders
Yeah, let's. COVID. Okay. Sure. Tell Tell me how this relates
>> Millions of people died of it. >> It had better
tie back to feminism. Why are you laughing? Cuz we're debating
feminism, and you're Why are you Millions of people died during
COVID. Why are you laughing about COVID?
Millions died.
Okay, it's funny. I think it has nothing Performative male right
here. Absolutely performative male. Very gross. Not cool at all.
>> Okay, well, why don't you shut up and let me finish
and make your Make him a sandwich again and let me finish. >> No,
you're You're disrespecting I'm trying to make It's a little
[__] up that he's on the side of feminism, and the
only times I'm finding him funnier when he's being misogynist.
WHY DON'T YOU SHUT UP AND MAKE YOUR HUSBAND A SANDWICH, YOU STUPID
[__]
THAT'S the only time he's compelling in any way. The point I
let you talk, be quiet. Let me talk. There's a reason why I'm
bringing this up. You said women You said women shouldn't be
in government
>> I am telling you during COVID, female leaders were far
more successful than men in dealing with COVID. Globally, women
only held 7% of leadership positions. Four of the top 10 countries
that were run by women and in this study, the death rates, 13
countries led by men, eight led by women, their male per capita,
214 deaths per million that were led by men. Led by women, 36
people per million. Look You can look up that stat. Now, why?
You could say maybe it was ego. You could say maybe it was bad
policy. You could say maybe it wasn't listening to experts. Whatever
the case may be.
Is it statistically significant? The women that were in power
in these countries led to 36 people dying per million. By the
men, 214 deaths per million. So, if your premise is that
Like, what if What if a woman was the president of the United
States when that was happening? And like in the United
unfortunately, as much as people don't realize it, state-based
policy is far more determinative determinative than federal policy
in the states, right? So, like technically, there was a male
leader in the states, and state policy is far more determinative
in terms of how many COVID deaths you have. Like, what are you
going to do then? Then that doesn't really reflect well at all,
I don't know. I That feels like a weird stat to pull. I I don't
know I don't know if it means much. >> Men should be in
power in these positions and women shouldn't, then what is your
explanation there? Because if women were in power, more people
would have died. Do you believe in freedom and
I think I've made that pretty clear. >> Okay, well, the
reason for those statistics is that women were notoriously tyrannical,
like the prime minister of New Zealand, locked down New Zealand
tighter than a prison camp. And the fastest way to get rid of
liberty and freedom is to put women in charge of the government
because they overwhelmingly bring in tyrannical welfare states.
>> Yes, by locking down their countries, by not letting
people go to work, by shutting down businesses, by forcing people
to take vaccines.
I mean,
he's not Sorry, she's not wrong that um that like the way you
save lives is more tyrannical policy. Also,
bro, how How could you possibly fail to keep COVID out of New
Zealand?
You're on a island, okay? You're literally on an island. That
should be the That is such an easy task in comparison to anywhere
else. You're on a You're on an island, so far away from most
of civilization, too. This is where she lost me. I mean, she's
not This is just the argument they're always going to make. We
watched Asmongold make this argument earlier today, actually,
if you're watching that. Is that women basically opt for safety
over liberty every single time, and that's why they shouldn't
be enfranchised. That's just a like a What do you say? Like a
philosophical talking point they're always going to put forward,
all these conservative types. So, first of all, first of all,
>> four specs in nations is >> all, I find it repugnant
that people in this crowd are laughing at the fact that less
people died because maybe you couldn't go to the mall, okay?
I find that despicable, number one. Number two, >> chasing
people around with masks, weren't you? >> No, actually,
I was one No, I was one of those people that almost died of COVID.
I was in the ICU Hold on a second. I was in the ICU for 2 weeks.
I saw people die around me. And the last breaths that And the
last No, it is sad. And the last breaths And the last breaths
that some of those people made, they didn't think that COVID
was real. The reason why this is a personal topic to me is because
I almost died from it. And I would imagine, sadly, I wish this
wasn't the case, I would imagine a lot of people in this room
know people that died of COVID. it. horrible. I don't want innocent
people to die. Of course, I want people to have their freedoms.
Of course I want people to go out and be able to live their lives.
The only point The only point that I was trying to make was that
women that were in these positions during that Man, I
>> COVID feels like such a
thing to argue over at this point. I feel like we should just
all put that time behind us entirely. We should just say there's
nothing to be learned. There's nothing to be learned. There was
nothing to be learned in COVID [laughter] at all. I don't know.
It just feels like Like I have opinions on it. And I I feel like
I can have the
Yeah, I see what you're saying, teeny tiny Tony, that there's
um that they're selling the medications on
It just feels like, man, I I have such a hard time listening
to people argue about it. Will you at least admit Nancy Pelosi's
hugging Asian day was stupid? Yes. Yes, we can admit that. >> That
time during COVID saved lives and they did a better job than
men. Now, if you think they're woke and they shouldn't have closed
every and everything should have been open, you're entitled to
that opinion. I disagree with you. How do you feel about forcing
people to take experimental vaccines? >> I've always said
I've always said that I never felt like the vaccines should have
been forced on anybody. I disagree with people that said that.
>> what women did when they were in charge of the >> these
women that were in charge of these countries and by the way,
that's not entirely factually accurate. So, let me I mean, everybody
forced vaccines, no? He really is He is really red? Yes, he is
really red. He's turned very red. Bro, what do you even do if
you're like this pale and you're like Irish?
You just like put makeup on like Trump? Is that why Trump has
a spray tan? So he can't tell when he's going to get spiked that
he normally be like super pale and turning red? But actually,
he gets the spray tan you can't even tell when he's going to
turn
Do you want us to look like a third world country? Is that what
you want?
No. You don't want that. Okay. Explain. >> Well, let me
ask you this. Are we still talking about feminism? What was your
position on vaccines? I don't think they should have been forced.
I got all my shots cuz I wanted to go out and do things. I really
miss being social with people. And you had to do it here to go
out and be social. Like I wanted to go play sports and stuff
and they literally wouldn't let you into
like any arena, anything
if you didn't have your vaccinations. Like you couldn't go play
sports. It was [__] up. So,
you know? By the way, >> Yes, we are. Yes, we are. Because
we have Bro, I played basketball during COVID, by the way. Basketball
with a mask on is horrifying.
Holy [__] A paper mask during basketball, you're
waterboarding yourself. It's crazy. Which they did. It didn't
matter if you're vaccinated, you still had to wear You still
had to wear your mask and they would kick you out of the
of the auditorium or wherever you were playing, the gym, if you
didn't keep your mask on. It's so [__] up, man. Three
on three with a mask, it's crazy. >> an entire society
and you said that men shouldn't vote. Wait, no. I played full
court basketball, too. It was crazy, man. What the hell? >> be
doing these specific things. I don't want to look like >> What
specific things are >> want to look like Afghanistan. You
are pushing You are pushing a narrative. >> So, it's either
progressive liberal enlightenment or it's sharia law in Afghanistan.
I didn't say that. What do you think Western culture looked like
for all of its history? Women can have plenty of liberties run
the country. Okay, about 5 minutes. For time Time is up. Right,
so we only have 5 minutes. So, time is up. >> all the time
talking about Trump and COVID and all kinds of Well, yeah, because
I gave you examples of women in government that I thought did
a good job. This guy got really cooked. Like it's actually
This is embarrassing how badly he did in this. Like I I usually
am totally willing to say, well, I couldn't have done better
than these people. Like it's actually really hard to argue in
the moment and all this. I could have done better than this guy.
I could have done way better than this guy. This is the one time
where I'll step in and go, you know what? I could have stepped
in on the fly with no preparation and done infinitely better
than this dude, okay? This guy is This guy sucks.
You didn't make a single compelling argument. >> I did.
They saved lives and obviously you don't care about that. Did
you say in your book that Miley Cyrus, Cardi B, Katy Perry, Beyoncé,
because they stick their tongue out they're invoking some Hindu
goddess and they hate men? Is that why they stick their tongue
out? >> literally say in their songs they hate men. Yeah.
No, no, no. You talked about sticking No, in your book you said
because they stick their tongue out >> What the hell? You
think Okay, can you please explain that to the According to your
theory, Gene Simmons must want to kill men, too. When women stick
their tongue out, could it just be possible that maybe they're
just doing it because they enjoy it or it's something they do?
>> said in the book whether they know it or not, this could
be invoking forms of ancient goddess worship. And they do in
their own songs talk about it. That's not So, hold on. So, because
Miley Cyrus sticks out her tongue, that must mean that they hate
and they want to kill men. I didn't say that. >> In your
book you were talking about invoking the Hindu goddess because
they stick their tongue out. Did you read the >> mean I
want to kill men, too. I don't know. Did you read the book? Cuz
you said you weren't I read excerpts of the book, sure. Yeah,
chat GPT? Cuz that's not what I said. >> Oh, so what did
you say? So, what So, talk to me about women sticking their tongue
Well, just briefly because it's not actually relative to whether
feminism is good for women and children. >> women for sticking
their tongue out. I'm not I'm attacking women. >> You're
right. They're Hindu goddesses and and they want men That's not
what I said. Anyone who's read the book will know. By the way,
go buy it. It's on Amazon. Occult Feminism, The Secret History
of Women's Liberation. It will explain though If I had it I would
use it to talk about how during the '70s uh there was a big goddess
worship revival in the West that coincided with feminism and
that they do still now. If you go to TikTok, look up the hashtag
witchtok and you will see feminists showing you how to perform
ritual abortions, how to worship ancient goddesses like Lilith
and Inanna and they take it very seriously. Do you know that
I'm not nuts? Witchcraft
Yeah, uh source? Witchtok?
My source is witchtok?
Okay. [laughter]
But Well, I don't know why he brought this up. I don't know why
she's
Oh, whatever. She wrote about it in her book. I don't I don't
care. We can continue on with this debate. I'm not crazy. Witchcraft
is Witchcraft >> Witchcraft is the number one fastest growing
religion among young women in the West. Did you know that? >> So, that's
not me. That's them telling you that. They're telling you they
believe it. I am I am very uh very aware of that. >> witchcraft
is real or not doesn't matter. Well, you know why? You know why
I feel that way? Because I think most people that are into that
think that it's inclusive. It's not oppressive, baby, like Christianity.
They feel like they feel like maybe that it's >> love witchcraft?
I'm going by why I I think you can make >> you guys. It's
very inclusive. It's very >> believe in the Bible, right?
And God killed 2.4 million people in the Bible. Is that oppressive?
I don't know. >> I I believe in Orthodox Christianity and
I'm not going to get into a Bible debate with you because it's
beyond the scope of this. So, here So, if we only got a couple
minutes left here. >> where So, do you have an argument?
Tell me how feminism has improved the lives of women and children
when I just opened with all these statistics proving I'll use
your argument because I want to move on to one other thing, but
I'll just use the argument that you used 20 minutes ago. It's
Um so, there's a lot of problems There's a lot of There's a lot
of problems in this country. I think we all I think we all know,
okay? There's a lot of We have We have Hold on. We have three
You know this guy Brian just debated Jesse Lee Peterson. I did
not I did not know that. We have a lot of problems in this country.
We've talked a little bit about it, right? Education, health
care, jobs, debt.
This is why Republicans, women, female Republicans are not
The reason why is because this is what Rachel is focused on.
She's not focused on those other topics that I just brought up.
I think a lot of people are. It's an uninspiring ideology that
you >> I'm talking about your ideology. I'm talking about
>> Patriarchy? I'm talking about your ideology and the
reason why I think you've made it very clear to everybody what
your ideology is. I think it's very clear what you think women
should be doing. Um so, listen. As I've said >> Having
families with good men who protect them and take care of them,
yes, I think that's great. And what if a woman And what Absolutely
not. What would you say to a woman
that hasn't found the right man? She's in her mid-30s. What should
she do?
Go to church. Go to church? That's So, you think church will
help I think she could find a good man in church. But there are
women out there, 30s, 40s, that haven't found the right man.
Well, is it that they haven't found the right man or is it that
they've been through about 50 men and haven't been able to lock
any of them down? I don't know. I've been with a handful Uh I've
been with a handful like less than five, so. Uh no, I'm talking
about I'm talking about that.
Oh my god, WE GOT TO GIVE HIM HIS LAURELS. That was bordering
on a good bit bit of [__] talk right there. It was
bordering on being
at least acceptable, okay? Five? Yeah, I don't believe that either,
but it's fine. We keep going. You agree with that? I didn't I
didn't initiate I was, but I didn't initiate 100 years ago you
wouldn't have been able to divorce them, right? I didn't divorce
them. I was abandoned by an abusive person. Okay, so 100 years
ago you wouldn't have been able to Yes, you would have. I just
told you that in the year 1900
Yeah, oh no.
>> Ah, this guy doesn't know the history at all and so
he's going to make an ass out of himself.
It's not that she left an abusive relationship. She was being
abused and the guy walked out.
He was abandoned.
So, now you look like a total ass. Guess what happened in the
'30s when women got abandoned? The same
YEAH, DUDE.
>> OH, NO. I've been talking about something I didn't understand.
Oh my. Uh-oh. 155,700
divorces were granted to women who were in abusive marriages.
So, yes, I would have. And by the way, one more thing. I would
be able to be here without feminism. This is a very stupid, silly
rebuttal. Yes, Mary Wollstonecraft Yes, the anti-suffragists
were having public debates against suffragists in 1848, you dumb
ass. So, women were allowed to speak publicly. Women have always
been allowed to speak. They've been allowed to write books and
they have been allowed to be part of the public discourse even
far before they could vote. He is ignorant and doesn't know his
history. So, so We really do have to transition. I hate to do
it, but we do have to as we are limited on time as we've already
gone over our time. You got to go to Q&A, man. I guess I
got to respond to that. In just Well, someone has to have the
last word during the open dialogue. We do have to go to the Q&A.
We'll ask you folks to get ready for in just a second. But first,
I want you to get ready for some groundbreaking news from Farm
Easy Bank, your trusted ally in Damn, sorry. I'm sorry, James.
I got to skip forward to where the questions are at. No, listen.
I respect J.D. Vance. I respect his service. I don't like him
personally. I don't like his policies. And so with that knowledge
being known, if I was just a man like a Rachel did dominate,
which is unfortunate cuz I don't exactly want to say that the
person who's arguing against feminism won.
And I I really don't think it's hard to argue for feminism. With
just that You don't have to break the mold. These arguments have
all been made. You literally have to watch one debate on this
and 99% of people don't [__] up these debates. Right?
99% of people can hit every single talking point to not get totally
rolled in these debates. This guy just sucked.
At the age of 16, could I just let her know that I got my draft
by eating a whole bunch of ice cream and dodging the weight requirement
and requiring Modern feminism advances the lives of real biological
women. >> Good question. First of all, if Okay, hold on.
Hold on. Hold on. First of all, my audience I'm going to try
to skip You got my friend Shapiro. people like policies remove
a bunch of this red tape. Okay. Literally. >> Okay. I I'm
not going I see him. I see him lurking. >> saying because
of fem Hold on. I see him lurking. I see the guy I'm waiting
for to ask a question. I see him lurking. >> Feminism
black >> You guys see him lurking? >> people wouldn't
exist. >> Yes, literally. Okay.
There you are. I see you. I see you lurking back there. I'm waiting
for his
I just want to see what I don't even know what Rob's going to
ask. I'm just excited for Rob's question. I'll respond to that
because I I'm not going to respond to something when I'm unaware
of it. I don't I I I If you're saying because of feminism, an
entire race of people wouldn't be here. I'll look that up. I'm
not aware of that. I'll look it up. How many years ago are we
talking about? Huh? Oh, did this guy come up and go, "Actually,
um Margaret Sanger and she was a feminist and she wanted to kill
all black people. Ergo, feminism almost killed all black people."
Is that Was that the argument? I'm not going to go back and listen.
I'm just going to straw man the argument. it would be like 1928,
the founding of Planned Parenthood with Margaret Sanger and the
same thing in the Okay, rewind a bit. Let's hear him out. Do
you want to hear him out? Do you want to hear the the I that
You know what? Just to check my biases, I'll go back and I'll
take a look, okay? Just to check my biases a little If
she wouldn't be here without feminism, so like if you go back
to the actual history of feminism, there's a big history in eugenics
and when you get to abortion, so I just want to know how you
feel about like if it actually was like feminism to the highest
extent, I wouldn't be here cuz they actually had a eugenics program
that was literally called in project and that was to [clears throat]
literally eliminate people like me, literally black people, >> saying
because of feminism, black people wouldn't exist? >> Yes,
literally. >> Okay. Literally. >> Okay. I I'm not
going to respond to that because of I'm not going to respond
to something when I'm unaware of it. I don't I I I If you're
saying because of feminism, an entire race of people wouldn't
be here. I'll look that up. I'm not aware of that. I'll look
it up. But, Now, I'm as much as I am kind of always looking for
another reason to hate liberal white women, I
I don't know if I necessarily believe that. I truly I would like
to believe it. I would like to. It is something that fits into
all of the things I would like to believe, but I don't know if
I It doesn't really fit with a lot of the other things feminists
claim to be about. So, I you know, uh I don't know. Let let my
biases rule and just say white women are the devil or uh do a
little bit of thinking. I'm not sure. >> How many years
ago are we talking about? Whenever I do that it would be like
1928, the founding of Planned Parenthood with Margaret Sanger
and the same thing in the UK with the Oh, there you go. founded
on eugenics I'll look that up. You can find me on Twitter and
I promise you I'll answer your question. >> I would love
to see the response to that. I will. Shoot me an email. I'll
put my email out there to everybody and I'm happy to answer that.
I'll look it up. Okay? Yeah. You guys can go Brian. I appreciate
that you said that like you had to bring up the personal stuff.
I think that is true and sometimes people don't understand when
you're having a So, for those of you who don't know who this
guy is, Okay. So, these two know each other and Rob is about
to bring up some personal [__] from Brian that Brian
doesn't want to hear. Brian doesn't want there. And Rob comes
up and he's like, "I get you had to you had to call this woman
out for her baby daddies." And I I appreciate it, dude.
>> I had a few debates with him and this this should be
a this should be a very should be a very uh The great ROB NARROWS,
EVERYBODY. THANK YOU. ROB NARROWS. I WAS JUST I was actually
going to give a couple of them. I'M SORRY. IT'S DIFFICULT in
debates like this where there's a personal nature and you have
to bring in things that are relevant to people's lives. It's
not really an insult even when you're implying she slept with
50 men. I understand how it's important to this debate and I
appreciate that. So, Rob doesn't think it's important. Rob's
saying that cuz he's got some [__] that he's going
to bring up that's going to be like awful for this guy. He does
not think that's important. He did not Rob did not think it was
important. It was a well-reasoned
point to point out that Rachel was a multiple times. He did not
think that. He doesn't think that, okay? Given that, feminists
such as Melissa Fabello and Caitlin her Caitlin Berg have written
extensively about the problem of men adapting feminist talking
points in order to harm women. Given allegations that have been
made against you of financially exploiting women and your treatment
of Savannah Hernandez, who was assaulted by a man and how you
mocked them, do you think Dude, I knew it was going to be something
like this. It was so obviously going to be LIKE
>> OH, NO. IS HE THE HE'S the liberal trapdoor spider?
He's the guy from the Stone Toss comic. No. No.
Get this man. Oh my god. It's literally him earlier in his career.
What's the Bane quote with the mask?
God, I haven't watched The Dark Knight in forever or The Dark
Knight Rises, rather. Something something about the mask, okay?
Before he put on the hat. This is him. This is just him. I know
it's just washed, but listen, it's a ginger. It's a bald ginger,
okay? It could be him. Before the hat. Before he adopted the
It's him. This is the question to both of you. Do you think that
you exhibit those same sort of toxic behaviors of men embracing
feminist talking points in order to attack women? >> I'm happy
to talk about that. So, first of all, I'll start with Savannah
By the way, nobody's been arrested in that situation.
I've been talking to Savannah for 3 years. Never have I ever
condoned violence or said somebody deserves to be assaulted on
either side of the aisle. I've said that on four national networks
since that incident happened. I said it on Piers yesterday.
My issue with Savannah Hernandez is What did he say to Savannah
Hernandez?
Cuz if he's had to address it multiple times, what the [__]
did he say? And by the way, the worst thing I said to her was
I called her a grifter, a right-wing grifter. Okay? Now, I also
interviewed somebody that used to work with her at InfoWars.
Had her on my show. Agreed with me. That doesn't mean that anybody
deserves to be assaulted. I've said that over and over again.
The family and the man who pushed her, which I know he regrets
doing that.
They've had death threats. There have been people that have threatened
to the wife and the daughter. I've had plenty of private conversations
with them and their attorneys. With that being said, I've also
said, "If somebody gets arrested, charged, and convicted,
let the chips fall where they may. What I don't like are people
like the Cam Higbys, like the Nick Sorchers, and others that
go to political rallies
Oh, that's probably true. >> get that viral moment. Now,
do I know if Savannah Hernandez wanted to be pushed or not? No,
I don't. But, I do know that when you go to these types of events
and you're looking for that viral moment,
I know exactly how this is going to go. I'd probably take this
guy's side on He's like too weak-willed about it, but I bet you
that this guy said something like it was one of those people
who's a provocateur who goes to some some like protest or something
and starts trying to like fight with people, like rabble-rouse
as much as possible, and then they get pushed by somebody, and
they go, "Oh my god, I'm such a victim." And he was like, "You
deserved
And maybe she got pushed on like the chest or something, and
then she's like, "Brian Shapiro supported me being
Right? I I think I think Brian Shapiro could be correct on this
and he would never ever
he would never ever like
be able to stand on it, I bet. I bet. And you're not a journalist.
That was my other issue with Savannah. Her first job was at InfoWars,
okay? She's never wrote articles about anything. She's not a
real journalist and when you go around the country asking people
what's a man and what By the way, I'm not a journalist either.
I've never said I was. When you go around Dude, this is such
a bad argument for his position.
This is such a bad argument. You're saying what's a man and what's
a woman. This is kind of turning into That doesn't make you a
journalist. And by the way, any allegations that you've talked
about, any,
are false. And why do I say that? >> We we do have to wrap
this up. >> Okay, well, this is important. I I had a death
threat yesterday
where somebody said they were going to go they they put my address
out there. I got into this I got into this business
He asked me the question.
He did ask the question. Kakampink says he interviewed the people
who attacked Hernandez and it's on video that she was assaulted,
not but violence-wise. Okay, I got it. I'm answering it. >> even
have to do with the question. >> Then then blame him. I'll
just just a quick follow-up. I'll just say Rob's got a major
advantage here because in terms of physiognomy, this guy does
look like he looks. All right? I'm sorry. It's not the tech tone
kind. It's like the I'm going to be the feminist. We're going
to all go out for like shots after and then I'm going to slip
something in your drink and we're going to go back to your place
and you're not going to remember anything. You're not even going
to remember I was there. That's the type he is, okay?
Not the tech tone type. Not the forceful type. The like in and
out.
The special ops type, okay? That's what he is. He made claims
Wait. That's not what he is. That's not what he is. That's not
what he is. That's what he looks like. I'm sorry. I meant that's
what he looks like. From a prejudicial standpoint, that's what
he looks like. I I don't know that's what he is, okay? Let me
ask you The green beret whatever. Yes, exactly. Exactly.
He's a green beret of Okay, that's what he is. There is
Nobody even knows, okay? Nobody even knows that this guy was
there. He's a >> The answer is no. >> real quick,
I understand it seems your argument there is you have to be be
careful with accusations or it could lead to death threats. >> is
no. You you call Trump a pedo all the time. They just tried to
kill him like 3 days ago. >> Who's they? Who's they? Uh,
the person that anti-Trump
Do you Will you retract you calling Trump a pedo? And will you
acknowledge that rhetoric that >> What I have said What
I have said over and over
I regret calling Trump a I should have been more direct and said
that when his daughter was a minor, he overtly certain way that
makes me suspicious of his intentions. I should have been more
specific. Rob, thank you. I will be more specific in the future.
Thank you.
I believe, just like I believe with Bill Clinton, that both Bill
Clinton and Donald Trump have probably did some horrible things
to women. Donald Trump is also a liable abuser. Donald Trump
is also named 30,000 times in the Epstein files. And if you're
going to say that
I believe that Donald Trump may have done some horrible things
to kids.
Then maybe you should call out the other side, too. Donald Trump
just asked for Hold on. Six Democrats he called for them to be
executed 3 months ago. Donald Trump is the guy who said, "Rough
him up. I'll pay your legal bills." So, if So, if you're going
to call out one side, you better call out the other one, too.
You're done
You're done I answered your question. James, since Rob said that
was a question for both of us, I just want to quickly say this
guy who is the white knight defender of women and also a pedo.
You want to protect women, yet your very first DM to me was asking
how many beers my husband had to have in order to have said that.
I'll defend that. I'll defend that. And it goes to what Rob just
said. Here's the reason why I said that. She put out a tweet.
I shared a tweet >> Excuse me. Let me just answer. Let
me at least defend myself. She put out a tweet, a retweet, whatever
you call it. Hold on. I'm I'm pulling that back just in case
you >> call out the other one, too. You're done You're
done I answered your question. James, since Rob said that was
a question for both of us, I just want to quickly say this guy
who is the white knight defender of women and also a pedo. You
want to protect women, yet your very first DM to me was asking
how many beers my husband had to have in order to >> say
that. YOU KNOW WHY?
>> WAIT, I I MISSED THAT. I'LL I'LL CONFESS, but I said
somebody might have missed it. I missed it. That's crazy.
This guy This is like you should not
Oh, man. Why did he show up to debate Rachel? Why would you do
that? WHY WOULD YOU SAY THAT to Rachel? Well, I know why you'd
say that to Rachel. But, why would you say that and then show
up to debate her on feminism and be like the guy who's like taking
the side of women. That's just rough. Of course, she's going
to be able to use that. You're going to look like a complete
[__]
>> The only Unfortunately for Rachel, we are all covert
misogynists, so now this guy's cool, okay? He was looking terrible
the whole debate, but now you just revealed the only thing that's
made him look cool in this entire debate. I'll defend that. I'll
defend that. I'll defend that. And it goes to what Rob N just
said. Here's the reason why I said that.
He's going to make it a moral issue. All you need to do is keep
joking, right?
And I'll I'll point out she's never answered the question.
Makes you wonder, was Andrew Could Andrew even consent? Was Andrew
Was Andrew is my question, guys. I am an egalitarian. Was Andrew
Can somebody tell me? She put out a tweet. I shared a tweet >> Excuse
me. Let me just answer. Let me at least defend myself. She put
out a tweet, a retweet, whatever you call it. Doesn't matter.
She has a large
And she retweeted, or whatever you want to put it, a story about
me with all the Man, I'm such a I'm such a The way I look at
the world is weird. Am I the only person who in my head, when
I think about like Rachel Wilson, I just see she's like a mom
and somebody's wife? I don't even put her into the pool of people
I would call ugly. It's like when I see somebody who's like a
mom with a bunch of kids, I like remove her from the pool of
people I would even consider like calling that? Am I the only
Am I just a weirdo for
I just feel like, hey, bro, this this woman's like taking care
of her kids. Like Like what the [__] Don't Don't
do that. You're There's so much collateral damage right there.
Like she's just She's doing her best, man. Okay, that's normal.
All right. The worst My sister passed away at the age of 37.
The person in this article, she doesn't care. Yeah. Again, she
doesn't She can give two I'm answering why I'm defending why
I called you that, why I said that. Because I was Okay, but it's
an excuse to call people Get lost. Go ahead. I'm saying you don't
give a [__] about women, No, I don't give a [__]
about
>> She has no idea. This guy Some people
Some people say this guy is the I don't I don't even know how
to make the joke, okay? Yes, the green beret of Okay, he's in
and out. You never see him. You never hear him. In and out and
you never know. Yes, he is a sneaky That is so true, Rachel.
HOW DID YOU SENSE IT? Like we're communicating across time and
space. He pretend He pretends to be a feminist so that he can
get into women's space.
She knows her stereotypes. She knows which stereotypes to lean
into. She is a true conservative, okay? She knows exactly which
one to lean into there. Let's go. Okay, so Brian, we would agree
that a man a man that turns 18 years old cannot willfully opt
out of Uh, is the woman who's got kids with different men with
Yeah, yeah, yeah. This is the person Charlie's blowing up. >> conscription,
correct?
What duty to this country can a woman opt out of? What duty to
this country that can a woman opt out of? Can they not opt out
without consequence? Yeah. I mean, you know, I I guess nothing.
Yeah. Exactly. The other point is we would under we would also
agree that men unfortunately hold the monopoly on violent statistics
in the country, right? Um, yeah. I would say that's probably
>> trans woman
What is a trans woman? What do you mean, what is a trans woman?
>> What biologically is a trans woman?
I've already said Were you not paying attention? I said if you're
born a man, I believe you're a man. I believe if you're born
a woman, you're a woman. >> the statistics for why trans
women shouldn't be allowed in men men women's >> that's
just ridiculous. I can't believe people are clapping at that.
This is so Hold on a second. Let me respond to
What a ridiculous thing
I mean, I'm I'm sorry. Maybe the argument doesn't work. Maybe
it's it's [__] up for some reason I can't think of.
But, wouldn't that give you the Like depending on the statistics,
couldn't you just racially segregate bathrooms, too?
If that Like wouldn't you by that same exact logic be able to
racially segregate bathrooms? thing to say. How is that ridiculous?
So, her Be quiet. Let me I hear I hear all the Of course, your
mind would go there. Well, no, it's it's that you don't prejudge
people and that the statistics are not like that different or
that crazy that you want to go and like shift all of the stuff.
Like it's
It's just not an actual issue. the time? Uh, again, the trans
issue again. When we talk about mass shootings in this country
and when there happens to be a trans shooter, everybody says,
"Oh, look at that. It's It's another trans person." It's almost
like you're wishing it's a trans person. Less than a fraction
of 1%. Less than a fraction of 1% of all the mass shootings in
this country are conducted by trans women. You know the demo
is? Usually, it's young white men. You could look up that statistic.
So, I'm not going to answer anymore. You're saying black people
are more violently statist violent statistically? No, I never
said a race or anything. I said, "Couldn't you make the argument
for racially segregating
I didn't say that. I didn't say what you said. You went to black
people and said something about black people that I never said.
Stupid trans question. This is so insane and ridiculous.
So, you've shown a lot of righteous indignation throughout this
debate. I wouldn't say that.
>> I'm honest. I wouldn't say that. I'm shooting it right
back at her. I wouldn't say that. It's my Yeah, it's my